son to
move oh and then oh wow oh my goodness
oh wow had a nowhere so this is what led
to their fight I don't got to worry
about finishing your coach will finish
you in the back like you're used
to don't worry about that you think your
dad beat this of you you you your dad
doesn't have on me I'm going to
show you what it's like to beat you I me
all every childhood memory you have is
going to come back when I'm in there
with you every the one the one where you
li B at night where your dad comes in
and he beat your out I will take
your soul you understand you
the thing I don't I don't have a
problem with trash talk I get like you
are you are Fighters you are in the
fight business Sean Strickland should
expect this when he talks as much trash
as he does but I'm sure that that
strikes a nerve and I do think that's a
little bit of a different level from
saying hey you and your you know you and
your coach playing touch butt in the
park or whatever it is